what's going on guys this is Rob and we
have hit 500 subscribers and that's a
very exciting thing to me in fact I
think has it right now we might even be
a little bit over 500 subscribers we
might be closer to to 540 or something
like that but you know this is extremely
exciting to me this is really kind of
you know a little overwhelming you know
I realized that 500 subscribers isn't a
ton of subscribers in the grand scheme
of YouTube when you have guys like
PewDiePie that have millions upon
millions of subscribers but you know
when you consider the fact that I've
only been doing this for four months or
so you know that's a pretty big deal at
least for me it is you know it's it's
it's pretty amazing it's really kind of
incredible to know that you know people
have been so receptive to the videos
that I've been uploading and you guys
have been so welcoming in terms of your
comments and your suggestions on what it
is that I should do in terms of making
adjustments to videos or topics for
discussion you know it's really just
kind of a of a really fun thing it's
really kind of an amazing feeling you
know to have to know that that um you
know people care about what I'm putting
on the internet but you know it's it's
it's interesting you know it's it's kind
of crazy you know and I don't know what
direction this channel will take you
know I don't know if and you know one
year I'll have a million subscribers you
know or if in two years I'll still have
500 subscribers you know I don't know
you know how big this channel is going
to get but I do think that there will
come a time when this channel will grow
to a huge size will have a huge
subscriber base and people will look
back at the very beginning they'll look
back at my first video on jason wyngarde
and they'll start moving forward and
they'll say man Rob you know you really
built an amazing channel you really did
you know turn this into something that
was absolutely fantastic you know where
people would be inclined to pat me on
the back and say man Rob he did a great
job I'm being kind of point a finger to
you guys and say it's because you guys
made this channel what it is I mean I
just make videos that are easy to
understand and they're designed for
people who want to refresh themselves on
comics or who don't know anything about
these individual characters or
storylines or or comic book superhero
teams or villain groups you know that's
all this is designed for and you guys
are the ones that have subscribed you
guys are the ones that have joined up
and you guys have made this channel into
some
you know the fact that you guys are part
of this you know is really kind of an
indicator that you guys are just as much
of a channel of this channel as I am you
guys are just as important as I am and
and I really kind of feel like a lot of
people on YouTube don't really say that
they don't really tell their subscribers
that you guys are just as much a part of
my channel as I am but I want you guys
to know that that's the case I want you
guys to know that I don't you know kind
of sit up on high and say you know be
happy that I'm providing videos to you
guys you know I'm really kind of humbled
by the fact that you guys have been so
receptive and I'm really kind of humbled
supportive in terms of the videos that
I've been uploading you know so again I
don't really know what direction this
channel is gonna take in terms of how
big we're gonna get but I do think that
we have amazing days ahead of us and I
really do think that we are going to
have some great discussions and some
great topics and I really do think this
channel is going to grow to do something
absolutely fantastic in the realm of
YouTube and Marvel Comics so with that
being said again I do want to say thank
you and I really appreciate everything
you guys have done so far and here's a
look into 500 more subscribers so I will
catch you guys later peace